l'équipage de transports canada à bord
de l'aéronef dash7 est un peu différent
ce matin en plus du pilote et des
techniciens de bord deux observatrices
de mammifères marins sont du voyage
on va focus est fort peu dérangé pendant
six à sept heures
sept heures de vol en rase-mottes à 1500
pieds ou 500 mètres au dessus de l'eau
leur mission est de repérer les baleines
noires leur position leur nombre et la
date de l'identification
elle va avoir des caractéristiques
physiques cl un dos tres tres noir et
une absence de nageoire dorsale est sur
le dessus de la tête il faut qu'ils y
avoir ce qu'on appelle les callosités
mais ce n'est pas si facile après tout
la baleine noire est en voie de
disparition
il ne reste que 450 individus dans le
monde
une baleine noire
c'est un peu comme trouver
des cuisines aiguille dans une botte de
foin ouais le dash 7 est un laboratoire
volant on a remplacé les sièges par de
l'équipement informatique à la fine
pointe de la technologie
lorsqu'on va changer la lèvre rouge vous
voulez pouvoir et souffre de la malène
c'est ainsi plus facile à la détecter
pour serge liger officie de surveillance
c'est une toute nouvelle aventure où la
surveillance est intéressant passé
quelque chose de nouveau ces nouveautés
même jour tu as fait la surveillance des
milieux marins ça fait on voit toujours
quelque chose de différent tout haut les
observatrices de mammifères marins
aperçoivent les premières baleines au
large d'anticosti fausse alerte ce ne
sont pas des baleines noires mais des
baleines à bosse et des rorqual la
saison commence 6 euros dans mahler
commencent à arriver donc la nourriture
s'installe dans les semaines à venir les
voit venir vont avoir encore plus c'est
sûr
l'histoire qui s'écrit et toute nouvelle
pour la baleine noire n'ayant jamais été
observé en si grand nombre dans le golfe
saint laurent
le dash 7 volera au moins deux fois par
semaine au cours des prochains mois les
vols du dash 7 serviront à mieux
documenter la présence des baleines
noires qui se trouvent dans les lignes
de transport maritime l'an dernier douze
d'entre elles sont mortes dans le golfe
saint-laurent en raison de collisions
avec les navires et dans pétremand dans
des engins de pêche
il est à espérer que les données
recueillies partagent 7 et son équipage
contribueront à une meilleure
coexistence entre l'activité humaine et
les baleines noires is interest and back
radio-canada au dessus du golfe saint
laurent
[Musique]